this morning prosecutors are moving to
legally separate David and Louise Turpin
from their 13 children who were rescued
from their home the Southern California
couple has pleaded not guilty to
multiple charges of torture child abuse
and false imprisonment some 20 people
have offered to take guardianship of the
Turpin family a family relative
reportedly says the children's mother
may have been motivated by a desire to
be famous
David beg no is here with new evidence
the alleged abuse was discovered just in
time David good morning the details get
worse than where we learn good morning
they do we are hearing that the terpenes
arrests came as they were planning to
move to Oklahoma now a source tells CBS
News the children told authorities their
dad was either recently transferred or
fired the 13 siblings are expected to
find new homes this week and could be
prevented from ever seeing their parents
again after last week's initial
appearance before a judge David and
Louise Turpin are expected back in court
today to face a restraining order
they're accused of abuse that lasted
four years including putting some of
their 13 children in Chains with the
children's expected release from the
hospital this week a source tells CBS
News officials want to make sure that
the children do not visit their parents
in jail fearing any conversations could
taint the ongoing investigation Louis
Turpin's brother tells Inside Edition
that dressing the kids alike was done
partly to position the family as future
reality TV stars
I believe that my sister wanted a
reality show because you know the very
last conversation that I had with her
before all this happened she did
actually say that she feels that they
would be perfect for TV at one point
sliding glass door lessons Billy Lambert
says Lewis Turpin bragged about having
more children than the star of Kate Plus
eight which was among the hundreds of
DVDs found in the family's garage praise
to Jesus another relative David's
brother Randy Turpin is president of a
Christian college in Ohio and he wrote a
book about the spiritual benefits of
fasting a source close to the
investigation tells CBS News Randy told
authorities in California on Tuesday
that he wanted to explore the
possibility of adopting the children but
before those discussions can happen
officials want to talk to him about
another matter whether he knew about the
past abuse officials insist their top
priority for the children whose names
we've learned all start with the letter
J is their ongoing well-being Mary Parks
works with the Riverside County's
Department of Public social services
we've heard all the adult kids are
together at the hospital why is that
whether you're in foster care or you're
available for adoption or whatever the
case may be we make every effort
possible to keep those siblings together
so all of the siblings are still being
cared for at a hospital in California
right near their home in Riverside
County but that is about to change the
source tells CBS News that the county
has one conservatorship over the adult
children and that they will be moved to
a supervised living facility today and
starting tomorrow the six minor children
will be split actually going to two
different foster homes David what
progress has the county made in terms of
finding adoptive homes so they had a
home John but the family that they had
home that they chose sight unseen spoke
only Spanish not much English they
rejected that family and now they're
moving into the process of finding
another family that's already approved
within the foster system that can take
the kids in that's a shame they have to
split up
we still don't know the mode of not that
anything they could say would make any
sense not heard anything from
authorities but why they did this we
went to the jail we tried to talk to
them we got on the list to talk to the
mother and then she denied us David
thank you very much but